[Music]
you guys it's happening they're back
you guys it's happening
and they're upping the glam factor just
tune in because you never know what's
going to happen on monday the
kardashians dropped a new teaser for
their upcoming hulu series titled what
else
the kardashians and it's chock full of
fancy drone shots glamour and according
to the famous fam a whole lot of
transformation over the last year
we've seen such transformations from all
of us
of course last week fans got their first
look at footage from the series which
teases a closer look at courtney's love
with travis barker
[Music]
we know we'll see the family celebration
following the proposal thanks to this
tick tock by travis's son landon yeah
that right there is the kardashian
camera crew
and when e.t recently caught up with the
musician's ex and the mother of his kids
landon in alabama she said she supports
them popping up on the show i won't be
tuning in
however
um you know i think it's fine if you
know this is an opportunity that they
want to be a part of and you know my
main concern is always you know my my
children are my first priority and you
know that's one thing that you know
travis and i you know do agree on it's
probably the only thing we agree on but
you know our children come first and
their happiness and as long as you know
the kardashians are good to my kids you
know that's all that matters to me as a
mom you know as long as they're happy
and then you know that's that's the key
the trailer also teases the moment
travis barker proposed to courtney back
in october quartz momager kris jenner
gets emotional and gives the push
founder a big hug after saying yes to
the blink 182 drummer and kim who is
currently in the middle of a divorce
from her third husband kanye west takes
a playful dig at herself this makes me
so happy
she's never had a reaction like that for
me and it's happened like a few times
and while there's no sighting of kanye
in the latest trailer fans are hoping to
learn a little more about the couple's
fallout since they're split the 41 year
old kkw beauty founder started dating
comedian pete davidson following her
hosting gig on saturday night live back
in october i like you just the way you
are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
and on monday a source told et that the
grammy winner is having fun with cheney
jones you know the model who looks a
whole lot like his estranged wife i
think you have to have a sense of humor
e.t source says the relationship is by
no means serious and kanye is mostly
spending time with cheney as a publicity
stunt the two were first seen together
earlier this month stepping out for
dinner in malibu and on monday cheney
shared this snap to her insta story as
the pair vacations in miami captioning
the selfie with a black heart emoji
i'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face
but back to that new kardashian reality
show i love it the series is set to
premiere april 14th on hulu and back in
october chloe told ellen degeneres she's
thrilled to have the cameras documenting
her life again we're streaming and we
get to have a much quicker turnaround
than previously and we're really excited
they're here now in the back shooting
with us and
we're so happy to be you know up and
rolling again
[Music]